un cadeau un tape de ballons
multicolores un tas d'artistes tous les
ingrédients étaient réunis pour que ce
noël soit exceptionnel les 60 enfants de
la rue du dragon pouvait tout et ouvrant
les yeux le plus beau cadeau leur a été
offert huit jours avant poursuit
l'occupation de cet immeuble vide
ils ont un toit eux et leurs familles
mal logées ont aussi longtemps avant
c'est mieux ici ou quoi pourquoi conviés
à la fête les gens du quartier sont
venus rencontrer leurs nouveaux voisins
écoutez albert jacquard un des
porte-parole des mal logés par curiosité
ou par solidarité
ces seuils de comprendre les causes
qu'on veut y gagne de l'argent
ce qui n'empêche pas de rire ensemble
nettoyage présentera trois chars j'ai
pas de vrai noël sans distribution de
cadeaux
tous ces cadeaux la bahia les gens du
quartier les gars assez compliqué est
ainsi bien hier ses réverbères qu'à
faire les choses enfants las
essentiellement les gens du quartier
il ya un comité d'établissement d'edf
qui à faire les choix aussi des enfants
ça vient un peu partout avec à la clé
une franc succès
image le volant joyeuse images de fêtes
fixé pour tous les objectifs par toutes
les caméras
serons nous encore là dans quelques
semaines quand noël sera loin pourvu que
nous ne devrions pas laisser cuire